so
we won't get through the whole attention
lecture i saw this coming i just felt
like that last bit was important enough
we'll cut as needed but i do want to
talk about attention and let me start by
uh sharing you with you some of the key
ideas about what attention is
okay
so to get into the mode of thinking
about those let's consider the following
question
how do you feel about people driving
while talking on their cell phones
smart
not smart
and while you're thinking about that
also consider the case like let's
suppose that you have had a hands-free
setup so you don't have to be looking
down on your cell phone or typing away
um
or holding your cell phone
maybe that's okay
what do you think
is there no problem with driving
while talking on your cell phone
provided you're not looking down and
pecking away at it
yes what do you think
i wonder what you really think i know
what all the you know pr says
is it fine
yes
i would say it depends on like whether
you're driving like if the road is clear
and it's like your usual path it's like
driving is pretty automatic at that
point but if it's like high traffic or a
new area and i think it would have a
significant effect
totally
my rule is if i am talking on my cell
phone
certainly if i'm turning left i put the
damn cell phone on my lap and i tell
whoever it is i can't
i can't talk to you and turn left at the
same time all right turning left is the
hardest thing we do
self-driving cars can't turn left have i
mentioned this how does a self-driving
car turn left it turns right three times
why is that because turning left is
social cognition
it's like
do they see me do they know i'm here are
they looking at my indicator do they
realize i'm gonna turn left this is hard
this is social cognition nobody's
mastered that yet anyway it's hard for
us too
anyway the real question here is not for
me to lecture you about driving
but to think about why
is that a problem why can't you talk to
a person
and pay attention to driving what is the
big deal
right
and so the intuition is we have some
kind of limited processing ability okay
we're not like
super super computers who can just do
millions of things at once we have some
kind of limit in how much stuff we can
handle okay and i think everybody will
have this intuition
um
you can't think about lots of different
things at once i like to think of this
as the toaster model of cognition
that is you plug in the toaster and the
light stem right so if everything's on
the same circuit there's some kind of
unitary thing resource that's limited
and it's more of it goes here less of it
goes here
okay so obviously we don't have simple
circuits like that in our brain and the
relevant
uh scarce commodity isn't just
electricity it's not electrons it's some
other kind of occult thing we don't
totally
understand but there's still some sense
in which some of our mental mental
processes are on the same circuit okay
i'm assuming everybody's sharing this
intuition here
so think about this how many people feel
like you can listen to music and read
difficult stuff at the same time raise
your i'm curious how many people feel
like they can do that
only a few
that's so interesting
sort of yeah i can't do it at all like
at all like even background music that i
don't even care that much about
someday i mean i think these are really
stunning individual differences i don't
i don't know if there's any good work on
it i haven't seen it but i think it's
really interesting
um some people can some people can't i
don't know what's up with that
um
how about um recognizing faces and
scenes at the same time
can you do that yeah how many people
feel like you can sort of recognize a
face and a scene at the same time
right um in fact michael cohen who gave
that lecture on brain computer
interfaces a month ago or so
showed some beautiful work
that actually you are better at
recognizing
a face in a scene presented
simultaneously
then two faces
or two scenes
can you think why that might be
yeah isabel
say more
um
if you see
somebody in a familiar place
uh
either it even helps you identify them
as oh i know that that person and
obviously they're there
right so they can go together into a
thing maybe chunk it as a thing or
something that's a good answer it wasn't
the one i was fishing for
um yeah jimmy
think of it like if like
people and places are like separate
components like separate things that
your brain calculates if it's like two
faces like you have to calculate this
thing or the face
number one before going to face number
two whereas if it's
exactly
exactly and you do right you have an ffa
and a ppa and they're friends right
so what michael showed is not just that
you can recognize a face and hold it in
working memory a face in a scene better
than two faces or two scenes
but the degree to which you have that
cost of doing two things in one category
rather than spreading over two
categories
is linearly proportional
to how different the activation patterns
are for those categories in the ventral
visual pathway
so faces and scenes are totally
different from each other and so you get
a big benefit
for
for separating your two items across
across faces and scenes
other things that are more similar in
their pattern of response
in the ventral pathway like faces and
bodies you get a smaller benefit
okay so it's consistent with this idea
that to the degree that we have separate
processors you can do to some extent
processing in parallel okay
it doesn't explain why why not everybody
can
uh read and listen to music at the same
time because as i argued a few weeks ago
these things don't overlap at all
so there are many mysteries but there's
some some intuition there
okay to get a little more intuition
about uh limited processing capacity can
you guys see when i was sitting over
there last time i couldn't see the
screen at all
can you guys see it
it's okay all right yeah
uh not for me
instrumental music no lyrics still a
problem so i i don't know i mean i'm
sure there's a literature on this i just
don't happen to know it i'm just trying
to share the intuition
so i i don't it's not it's not the only
thing for me
um
okay so what i'm going to do this is a
super low tech demo i'm going to show
you an array of colored letters grab a
piece of paper or something where you
can write down a few letters
and i'm just going to flash up one array
very quickly and i want you to
write down as many of the blue letters
as you can
okay ready
there's only a few of them so you can
okay ready here we go
okay write them down
last year everyone got all of them so i
tried to go a little faster this time
okay
um
okay we're gonna do it again ready
there's gonna be another display and
you're gonna write down all the blue
letters everyone ready here we go
okay just want to share the intuition
the probability did anyone miss the n
here okay how many people got the n
okay nobody's gonna admit it
i wanted a few people to miss the n
right i really did zip through i
probably cheated and went this one made
this one go faster you missed it okay
thank you i'm sure a few others did okay
anyway the point is
um that um if you do this properly in a
lab the probability of detecting it here
is much less than there
right
so
what does this show
it shows that we have limited capacity
we can't process
all of those blue letters in parallel
right when there's a single one you get
it just fine but when there's a bunch
you don't necessarily get it right
okay
it also shows that we have ability to
select the information
right so you weren't bothered by the red
letters if i'd asked you right after
about the red letters you probably
couldn't report any of them at all
right
there's a whole field that studies that
we won't get into okay
um
so in fact the probability of reporting
the n in these two displays is
independent of the number of red letters
they just don't matter they are not
entering into that limitation whatever
it is the limitation is only for the
ones you're paying attention to the blue
ones
okay um
okay
so
why is our mental capacity limited
okay
nobody really knows an answer and i
actually think this is a really
unsatisfying part of attention research
because it's just it sort of seems
obvious but i think it's not
so
sometime in the next 10 or 20 years some
smart computational person will analyze
this well and get a more satisfying
answer but right now here's where we are
the standard story is well
you know we have only so many neurons
and so much capacity and you can't do
everything at once right
so we can't process everything in the
whole visual field at once
that's the standard story
but the reason i find this unsatisfying
is like why the hell not right we have
all this all this parallel stuff for the
whole visual field at least in the first
few stages of processing and we have
quite a degree of parallelism after that
so i think you know that's a standard
story but i'm just marking that i don't
find it very satisfying yeah
a second answer which i think is also
not totally satisfying but also a little
bit right at least is that typically
you're only going to do one action right
you're going around in the world let's
forget you know colored letters on a
display in a lab let's think about a
person walking around in a busy city
street doing something right there's
there's typically only one or a very
small number of things you're going to
do next like walk down the sidewalk and
not bump into people or pick up this
object right
you don't need to act towards all the
things
in your world and in fact if you if you
had to so given that you're only going
to do one thing
why distract the whole rest of your
motor planning system by feeding it all
this information that it's just going to
clutter it with garbage why not give it
just the information it needs okay so
that's a standard story it's very
squishy and vague but hopefully
intuitive
um
and there's some nice um
kind of compelling examples that
illustrate this so
there's a fish called a pike fish that
preys on smaller fish called
sticklebacks okay
and if you stick a pike fish in a tank
with sticklebacks
it will catch the first stickleback
faster
if there's only one in the tank with it
than if there are 10 in the tank with it
okay you might think you've got 10 to
choose from
you'll get a fish faster
but 10 is more distracting right
and so maybe our action planning systems
also prefer the single stickleback
there's no computational precision i'm
just sharing intuitions with you
okay
so let me give you some more evidence
that there really are
uh significant capacity limits in
perception
um and that in fact there's a lot of
stuff right in front of us that comes
right onto our retina that we don't see
okay
so i'm going to show you uh an example
i'm going to show you a picture for just
a few seconds and i want you to just
look at it and then i'm going to ask you
some questions about it okay here we go
okay
so
how rich a percept did you get did you
see lots of stuff and get lots of detail
or do you just feel like you just have
the vegas sense of a few buildings a
street that's it how many feel like they
got a lot of
pretty good detail
no one does or everyone's bored in a
wedge
the colors of buildings the presence of
objects uh details on the architectural
styles where an awning was that kind of
thing
most people looking at this feel like i
mean who knows what it means i mean
we're just we're just sharing intuitions
here but most feel like that was pretty
rich i have a sense of it i have a sense
of maybe what country that's in and what
kind of stuff is there and what kind of
the style is you get a feel for the
place all that kind of thing maybe not
every damn detail but lots right so the
general intuition most people have is a
fair amount of detail
okay
well let's look at that some more this
is actually a very very heated topic
right now
um
me and michael cohen published a paper a
couple years ago called the bandwidth of
perception which is an effort to grapple
with this question of how much
information is there in your current
percept right now and there are many
different perspectives on this
let's find out a little more with a
further demo
so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to show you
that picture again and it's going to
flash on a number of times
and each time it flashes on there might
be something that's different
so take notes on any differences you
might detect
okay
okay
okay what things changed
yeah a woman walking down the sidewalk
and
that's all i got
okay but she changed what changed about
her
other than like her pose
yeah
over the successive presentations was
she there sometimes and not others did
she change yeah she appeared or
disappeared okay good what else isabel
very good very good how many people saw
an awning change
maybe half of you okay
what else changed
the model of the car very good yeah
i feel like the shops changed but i
don't know whether or not
okay
okay you want to see how they changed
okay here's how it ended
here's how it started
are you surprised how much
raise your hand if you're surprised how
much changed yeah a lot
right
okay so what does that tell us
it tells us that either
the sense we have that we really saw a
lot of what's going on there
was wrong we didn't see as much as we
thought because if we saw as much as we
thought
we should notice
massive changes like that if you didn't
see the awning look over there i mean
how could look at the color changes
pretty major right
or we perceive all that stuff in the
instant and it just goes poof by the
time the next one comes along
that's one of the things the field is
fighting about those things are very
hard to tell apart not impossible but
hard
yeah
um
okay so most people feel like wow much
more changed than i thought i can't
resist one more hilarious demo
um
so
did you have you already seen this like
in 900 how many people have seen this
before
oh i don't want to bore you do you mind
seeing it again we could skip it it's
kind of fun
sorry do it okay okay
um okay so you're just going to watch
this video and just track things because
there may be changes happening here and
there and you want to notice them okay
here we go
[Music]
clearly somebody in this room murdered
lord smythe who at precisely 3 34 this
afternoon was brutally bludgeoned to
death with a blunt instrument i want
each of you to tell me your whereabouts
and precisely the time that this
dastardly deed took place
i was polishing the brass in the master
bedroom
i was buttering his launching scones
below stairs son
i i was planting my petunias in the
potting shed constable
arrest
lady smythe
but how did you know madam as any
horticulturist will tell you one does
not plant petunias until may is out to
take her away
it's just a matter of observation
the real question is
clearly somebody in this room murdered
lord smye who
precisely 3 34 this afternoon
was brutally bludgeoned to death with a
blunt instrument i want each of you to
tell me
at precisely the time that this dusted
indeed took place totally different guys
a rest
lady smith
it's actually an ad but it doesn't hurt
to get its message
all right it's a it's a british ad
with an important message but it's a
pretty impressive demo too wasn't it how
many people feel like lots of stuff
changed that they didn't notice
yeah that's intuition
so the idea here is that all that stuff
hits your retina
all of it kind of gets processed to some
degree
but it's amazing how much of it goes
unnoticed okay
all right oops sorry
okay
you might think okay is this something
that only happens when it doesn't really
matter okay you were looking for changes
but your life didn't depend on it what
about commercial pilots so here's a
classic study where they brought in
actual real commercial pilots with
thousands of hours of flying experience
and they had them fly in a flight
simulator they had them land a plane
on a um on a runway in the flight
simulator under foggy conditions
and i forget what percent i have to
cheat and look at my notes
doesn't say some it does i just not
seeing it some large percent of the
pilots
never saw this plane sitting right there
on the runway they landed the planes in
the simulator right through that plane
and when they were shown it subsequently
they were shocked and couldn't believe
they didn't see it
right they were using a heads-up display
that tells them their orientation where
the runway is and they're paying
attention to this stuff landing on the
runway and they just do not even see
that very relevant thing okay so it's
not just something that happens in like
weird psych demos
and funny movies uh even even for very
important things people miss absolutely
major
important information
okay
so what all this tells us is attention
is a filter that lets some information
uh into our awareness but completely
filters out of awareness a lot of other
information that lands on your retina or
your cochlea
okay
um
and there's two key properties of
attention that go hand in hand
one those capacity limits we've been
talking about you can't do everything at
once
and two selectivity that is there's some
way some subset of that information that
comes in and some way to select it
okay
all right so let's say a little bit more
about attention
um there's lots of different ways and
forms of attention so let me give you a
few
key distinctions about attention it's so
far it's just kind of a vague word that
gets used lots of different ways
um so
long ago the great helmholtz thought
about attention uh and realized that
there were two different kinds of
attention
so he noted way back in 1860
our attention is quite independent of
the position and accommodation of the
eyes
and of any known alteration in these
organs and free to direct itself by a
conscious and voluntary effort
upon any selected portion of a dark and
undifferentiated field of view
this is one of the most important
observations for a future theory of
attention
indeed it is
right so his point i think we did this
at some earlier lecture his point is you
can fixate on my nose right now okay
everybody fixate on my nose
not that it's that fabulous a nose it's
just served for the demo right now
and if i hold up different numbers of
fingers out here keep fixating on my
nose no cheating
okay
how many fingers are off to your left
the left side of my nose from your
perspective
okay how many fingers are off to the
right side okay you can do that you can
pull up this information or pull up that
information without moving your eyes
okay that's called covert attention
because the input is identical
and you are just somehow adjusting the
dials on your perceptual system to pull
up this or pull up that
okay so that's called covert attention
um to be unconfounded from overt
attention which is actually the most
powerful kind of attention over
detention you move your eyes from point
to point to select different information
okay so over attention is a much more
powerful filter
and we make about two to four eye
movements a second
and it's very powerful because the
center of gaze has very high resolution
information remember high density of
photoreceptors at the fovea in the
center of gaze and the density tails off
in the periphery so we have much better
information in the fovea than in the
periphery
okay so it's both photoreceptor density
and it's also cortical area
so in retinotopic cortex back here
primary visual cortex v1 v2 those
regions
you have
about 20 square centimeters of cortex
like that area of cortex pretty big
something like that
processing the central two degrees of
vision
okay a huge cortical area devoted to a
tiny little part of the visual world
and uh much less per degree for the
periphery okay so both at the
photoreceptor stage and at higher level
processing stages we vastly over
represent the center of gaze okay
that's why if you have loss of foveal
vision and macular degeneration it's
really awful you can't read or recognize
faces that's where you need this
fine-grained foveal information
okay so that means that making moving
your fovea and parking it on different
parts of the array is an extremely
powerful way to select different kinds
of information
so to give you a feel for how much
people do this and how they select
information
here's a um
video this is taken from a head mounted
camera of a person who is watching these
two people and the yellow yellow dot is
where their fovea is so they're talking
to my former postdoc matt and they're
fixating on his face as he talks
and
sometimes they take a peek at the other
person you can see there's very fine
grained adjustments
of where they look as this goes on and
now there's walking down the hall in
this building and they're following
her watch what happens when they turn
the corner check out the signs read the
little notices
look down the hall now watch what
happens when they go around the corner
oh new person look at the new person
right
sorry it's too dark to see what's going
on here oh this is a little fixation
patch where they're recalibrating the
eye tracker um to figure out to make
sure it's working here comes a new
person they look at his face it's a cod
back and forth between the two faces
right whoever's talking you look at them
and you collect high resolution
information from that person's face with
both head turns you can see they're both
head turns
and um and eye movements
okay you get the idea
i didn't totally explain so this is a
this is a head mounted camera and eye
tracker okay of a person who was walking
around the building encountering people
and was showing you both what was in
their field of view and where they were
fixating their eyes in that view so you
can see this really fine-grained
moment-to-moment sampling of visual
information all the time with over
detention with eye movements okay makes
sense
okay
okay first so that's the first
distinction about attention covert
versus over
okay
uh now you might say why would we bother
with this subtle
sophisticated covert attention when we
can just move our eyes and do overt
attention and i think there's a bunch of
reasons for that one is
other people can see where you're
looking
and there's sometimes you want to attend
to stuff over there and not let people
know
right
so there are many examples of this from
elevator eyes people who look you up and
down it's not politically correct it's
not nice it's not considerate people
notice if you do that so don't do it you
can covertly attend below the face if
you like but don't overly move your eyes
down there because they will know okay
we primates are very very attuned to
where each other are looking
uh we are the only primate who has
whites around the eyes
which i just heard a talk last week by
michael tomasello who's one of the major
primatologists and he says that the fact
that humans have whites of their eyes
that make it so easy to tell where
they're looking
must mean that we mostly want to share
information with each other about where
we're looking we're a very cooperative
communicative species
but not always sometimes we want to
sneak a peek at something where people
don't know the case that i notice all
the time is i'm at a conference and some
very familiar face comes along and says
hey nancy how are you and i'm thinking
who the hell is this and the whole time
i'm thinking i can see the name tag
right there i can't quite resolve it i
know that if i second down for a half a
second they will see it and i will be
busted
and so i'm sitting there with a name
right there racking my brain trying to
think who the hell it is anyway so there
are many cases like this where we don't
want to be caught
looking so those are all cases where you
might want to use covert attention
also sometimes you want to track lots of
things and you can't in parallel and you
can't foveate all of them you can only
fovate one thing
so i don't know anything about sports
but think of your favorite complicated
sports example where they're multiple
players moving at once and you need to
keep track of all of them
that would be a classic case of covert
attention because you could covertly
attend to several of them at once and
you have only one fovea well you have
two but they go the same place
okay so that's the second distinction
over versus covert
uh
only the first one right so the next
basic distinction of different kinds of
attention
are the kind where we decide where we
want to look versus the kind where
the stimulus draws our attention okay
so there are lots of examples like web
pop-ups are all designed to pull your
attention over it and covert even you
don't want to look at that damn thing
but you know the weird little dancing
figure they're all like optimized
to pull your attention over and make you
read the ad right and they're pretty
effective okay so that's called
stimulus driven attention or exogenous
attention it comes from the outside and
it pulls you in
okay
another classic example is pop out if
you look at this display it's very hard
not to notice and have your attention
drawn to that red thing
certain properties of stimuli that just
automatically capture your attention
okay
that is to be contrasted with voluntary
controlled attention that's like the
case we did before where you were
fixating on my nose it was totally up to
you whether i attended i mean i told you
to but you could have made up your own
mind and attended to neither and i
wouldn't have known right
so you can decide what you want to pay
attention to and as i think i mentioned
in i don't know what context a few weeks
ago thank god we can decide what to pay
attention to because there's lots of
stuff that goes on in the world that we
don't want to have dominate our mental
life
and
controlled or voluntary attention is one
way that we can
have our mental life dominated more by
things we want it to be dominated by and
less by
things we don't right
um so that's that notion here like for
example you're you know sitting here and
it's like noon and you're just thinking
okay i'm really hungry i'm really hungry
if you were my dog charlie your entire
mental life for the whole next half an
hour would be i'm so hungry i'm so
hungry i'm so hungry
but you're a person and so that thought
may impinge now and then but you can
drive it away and think about something
else because it's not going to get you
anywhere to focus on how hungry our arms
i know i just made it worse i'm sorry
about that
okay
okay another way the way that scientists
have typically stuttered voluntary
attention
as they asked subjects to do this and
much like the case we just did here's a
kind of very basic paradigm you have
subjects fixating on a cross and
typically in covert attention
experiments you want to make sure there
aren't overt eye movements and so you
have an eye tracker to make sure the
subject is keeping their eye on that
cross okay
and then you give them a little cue that
says pay attention off to the right
but don't move your eyes
okay
and then shortly thereafter a little cue
comes up and you have to hit a button
quickly that you detected the target
okay it comes at a variable delay so you
can't just hit the button
okay if you do that you find that the
reaction time to detect that target if
it's where you're attending is really
fast not much more than 200 milliseconds
which is damned fast right
now consider a case where you're
instructed to attend over here and the
way you get these experiments to work is
that these cues are valid eighty percent
of the time so there's a reason for
subject to the motivation for them to
follow your instruction so trying to
answer quickly and there's like okay
they're ready it's almost certainly
going to be over here but oops it's not
okay
then reaction time is almost 100
milliseconds slower which is a huge
effect in psychology 100 milliseconds
okay
okay so you're much slower to detect
something
um if it's at an unattended location
okay and if you have a neutral trial
you're somewhere in the middle
okay so that is
exogenous or um
voluntary attention
okay
and again this is covert attention no
eye movements
all right
um
so third distinction the example i just
gave you was spatial attention you're
attending to this location or that
location in space
okay that's probably the most powerful
and common kind of attention is usually
the things you're interested in are in a
particular place and you attended that
place and there you go
but it's not the only kind
you can have feature based attention
so if your utensil drawer is a hell of a
mess like mine is
um like this
if your task is to find the black
vegetable peeler
best of luck to you it'll take quite a
while
it's in there it's right there it takes
a while right
in contrast if the task is find the
purple rubber spatula duh
right okay so that's feature-based
attention you don't know the location in
advance you know something about the
feature you're looking for that it's
black or that it's purple
or round or square or whatever the
feature is okay so different ways of
different kinds of filters you can set
on your attentional system
okay so that's just to give you some of
the phenomenology of the different kinds
of attention
how does all this work in the brain i'm
not going to tell you how it works we'll
just focus mostly on what the brain
regions are
okay so let's go back to this case here
voluntary attention
so now the question is what happens when
you get this cue
you're not going to move your eyes but
you're kind of cranking up that part of
space
okay what's going on in the brain
right there
before the stimulus comes on
everybody get the question
okay you know you can sort of feel it
happening but what does that what does
that mean
well this is very amenable to a simple
functional mri experiment
and in the early days of functional mri
a whole bunch of people at once realize
oh right we can answer this
long-standing question of whether
early retinotopic parts of the visual
system are affected
just by a cue like that even before the
stimulus comes on
right
so and i think it was 1998 a whole bunch
of people started doing this in 1997. i
was one of them uh but a whole bunch did
it once in 1998 i think like
six papers were published all doing
versions of this next thing which is one
of those obvious ideas
um we got scooped but anyway
everybody got the same result so
basically if you just do a simple
comparison this is a version they have
subjects are fixating here there's two
stimuli
they're looking in v1 and v2
and if you just do a contrast of the
case where you're looking here and
you're attending waiting for a target
here versus waiting for a target there
without moving your eyes
you get a big contralateral
modulation in in v1 and v2 this is a
slice near the back of the head here so
this is a piece of
calculus or primary visual cortex
right and so you can see even before the
target stimulus comes on just attending
over there gives you a big baseline
increase in neural activity everybody
clear what's going on here
and of course you can do the opposite
one and see that it shifts to the
opposite side of space
okay
okay
so that's all before the stimulus comes
on you can think of it as priming the
brain kind of juicing up those neurons
getting them ready to go so that when
that stimulus comes through boom your
reaction time is faster
okay
um
okay so that's modulating
uh parts of visual cortex before a
stimulus comes on to get it ready
but we can also look at what is the
effect on a stimulus once it comes
through an attended stimulus or an
unattended stimulus
to show you that i'm going to show you
what kind of feature based attention
and what
ancient this is a paper we published in
1998 i think we this is not a
non-spatial version
so we gave subjects guess what faces and
houses and a little crosshair and we had
subjects in different blocks
say whether the two arms of the cross
were the same or different length okay
so vertical one is different length so
that's a different case
whether the two houses are same or
different
or whether the two faces are same or
different okay so actually it's spatial
and featural come to think of it because
they're in different places
okay
so we then looked in a bunch of regions
i'll show you the data from the fusiform
face area
and the key thing about this is in all
three tasks we had the identical stimuli
so there's always faces and houses and
crosses in the same place in your visual
field in all of those blocks it's just a
matter of which of those things you're
paying attention to
okay
so what do you think we'll see in the
fusiform face area
in this experiment
is it going to care
whether you're attending to faces
or attending to houses or attending to
the crosshair
same stimulus all the time
exactly what happens okay everybody hear
the prediction you'll still get
something
but you'll get more when you're paying
attention to it
okay so
here's the ffa response over time here's
the time course
and these gray blocks are the blocks
these are the different attending to
houses faces color houses faces
crosshair houses faces crosshair the
gray bars are when the subjects are
attending to faces
now here
uh
i actually can't quite tell
yeah i can sort of tell
you can't see it on the screen but there
are little rest periods between those
blocks so i'm trying to figure out if
you're right that there's some response
um greater than baseline i think there's
actually very little selective response
greater than baseline
by design we made this a whopping
attentional manipulation
so that all of the tasks are really
difficult and we're doing one of them
you just barely feel aware of anything
else in fact i vividly remember
the first time we ran this experiment i
was a subject in the scanner and i i did
the first block and i was doing um just
cross hairs
and i did i went through the whole
crosshair thing and it wasn't till the
end of the experiment i realized oh
right there were faces there i was just
completely unaware of them right so we
designed it to really
um so tie up your mental capacity that
you just didn't have processing
resources left for anything else and so
if there is a response to everything
else here is really low but you can see
certainly the attended thing is much
more
it's much stronger in the attendant case
in the unattended case
okay
so this is a general property like
basically all of the perceptual regions
we've talked about are strongly
modulable by attention okay
from from retinotopic regions on up okay
including v1
and in fact even including the lateral
geniculate nucleus
so one synapse up from the retina
you're already modulating activity there
by attention
okay
remember i remember i know i said this
but it maybe went by briefly you have 10
times as many connections down from
cortex down to the lgn as you have going
forward
okay one of the things they're doing is
setting up selective filters so that
only the stuff you want to process
makes it to higher stages
okay um yes so does this sort of
phenomenon generalize across the brain
areas
i mean it's it's like it's generally
true of pretty much everywhere yeah so
the intuitive physics thing is justified
so experiment two over there was you see
the same stimulus
exactly it's an instance of this exactly
right exactly right it gives us one of
gives us one of our paradigms in
functional mri studies have the same
stimulus vary the task okay some things
that some things don't work as well
things that are just very dominant
stimuli in this experiment if we hadn't
put the faces in the periphery and given
subjects a damn difficult task
the modulation wouldn't have worked
because faces are just so dominant
they're going to punch through even if
you don't want to right
like web pop-ups
uh you also i'm going to skip this
because we won't have time you could get
very similar things in primary auditory
cortex listening to high frequencies or
low frequencies these are all the same
stimuli this is voxel selective for low
freq frequencies voxel selected for high
frequencies you have a high frequency
input in one ear low frequency in the
other as you switch between those
responses toggle
okay
so all of that tells you the effects of
attention how it modulates activity all
over the brain but what is the source of
attentional signals in the brain
uh and that source is a set of regions
we have encountered before
sometimes called the fronto parietal
attention network these blue and green
bits up in here back here in the
parietal lobe up here in the frontal
lobe
and they're active when you shift
attention from one location to another
from one feature to another or when you
do any difficult attention demanding
task
we've also talked about them in the
other context of the multiple demand
system it's pretty much the same set of
cortical regions that pretty much any
time you do a difficult task almost no
matter what the task is these regions
turn on
so they're not just about visual
attention they're kind of about you know
basically controlling your mind
right
selecting information
making yourself do difficult things
who knows what what that is
computationally but these regions are
very systematically engaged
and they're particularly systematically
engaged when you're shifting attention
over different locations
okay so just to remind you in contrast
to everything else we've talked about
face areas music areas language areas
they're very specific for one mental
process domain specific these are the
opposite they're ludicrously domain
general
okay
all right
um
i'm gonna skip the video when the system
is damaged bilaterally all kinds of
weird stuff happens okay i'll post this
if you guys send me an email to remind
me i'll post this clip in balance
syndrome where you have bilateral damage
back there in these parietal regions
people can only see one object at a time
okay they're looking out at a
complicated thing like this and they
would see i see shash see anything else
no just josh nothing else there no just
josh right totally weird anyway so they
get locked on one thing they can't shift
attention
okay
um
okay i wanted to talk at least briefly
about awareness
so let's talk a little bit about
neural correlates of awareness
and
so first question is
if we want to study
perceptual awareness and not just
perception
how are we going to uncouple those
things
we've sort of talked about a few
examples with attention
with attention the thing you're
attending to is at least much more
dominant in your awareness than the
stuff you're not attending to even if
the other stuff seeps in a little bit so
that's one way
where you have the identical stimulus
but you were varying the degree of
awareness but another way i need you
guys to pass out the glasses
you want to both do that different sides
okay so i'm going to show you
a stimulus these guys are going to pass
around glasses let me say in advance i
want them back i use these every year so
drop them off here when you leave
okay so what you're going to do you put
them on either way doesn't matter
okay so first we're going to do optics
nothing interesting
so look at this stimulus
and close one eye
okay now look at it through the glasses
look at it through the glasses and close
one eye and you should see just a face
or just a house
and if you close the other eye you
should see the opposite does everybody
get that okay that's not psychology
that's optics the glasses are just
filtering one image into one eye and
another image into the other eye okay
this is all this is as a way to get
different information to your two eyes
okay now just look with both eyes
and don't do anything just kind of look
and if anything cool happens you can
kind of go
ah
or you can tell me what's happening just
watch doesn't always happen immediately
yeah quietly what's happening
sorry what's that
uh-huh
okay it changes from the house to the
face only when you blink yeah quietly so
at first when i first moved on i would
like i saw the house and the face super
close
and then you told us like put one eye
and then i would eyes again it like went
from the house to a feet uh-huh
uh-huh and then did it stay there or
does it keep flipping
okay if this is not working for you
don't panic there's nothing wrong with
you it's hard to get everybody's red
green balance the same um
yeah sorry question in the chardool yeah
ah
so i share your intuition i think i can
choose to but there's actually a whole
literature on that and the guy i was
collaborating with on this project 20
years ago insists that actually that's a
wrong intuition you can't choose and i
said oh the hell the hell i can't
i'm in the scanner being your best
subject ever because i'm switching
exactly when you want me to switch don't
tell me i can't switch he said no the
literature says you don't anyway i don't
know the latest on that yeah
kind of related to switching that it
feels a lot harder to see the house in
the face
yeah
yes it's not optimally set up so that
it's perfect for each really the reason
i do this is to amuse myself looking at
all of you with you
thank you um
okay
so you can keep looking or not but i'm
going to tell you what's going on here
the cool thing about this is when if it
didn't switch for you the person is is
there anybody for whom it didn't switch
one okay so maybe your color vision or
who knows what but anyway
okay if it doesn't switch there's
nothing wrong with you the percept
everyone else has is it just flips every
few seconds from one to the other okay
so what's cool about this is when it
switches nothing changes on your retina
only your state of awareness changes
and that gives us a wonderful level
lever to study what goes on in the brain
when awareness switch is unconfounded
from the stimulus
okay
it's like varying attention but it's
more powerful
so of course
we put people in the scanner we pop
mostly me and a few others but anyway we
popped ourselves in the scanner we just
taped these things on our forehead nice
low-tech experiment we looked at that
exact stimulus okay
and we scanned the brain while people
sat there watching the stimulus flip
back and forth okay
so this is a stimulus for the whole
experiment this is the percept it
switches back and forth the subject has
a little button box so they can say now
i see the face now i see the house
now of course the choice of a face in a
house was not random
why did we choose a face in a house so
that we could look at the response in
the ffa and the ppa
ffa loves faces hates houses ppa loves
houses hates faces perfect right
so the question is are they going to
switch when your percept switches even
though nothing's changing on your retina
what do you guys think
switch or switch how many people think
it's going to switch
how many people think it's not going to
switch
a few okay all right so that's what we
did
here is now the raw mri time course
averaged over the ffa an average over
the ppa
for one
five minute experiment or three minute
experiment in one subject probably me i
forget
again stimulus is the same the whole
time the letters are the times when the
the subject pressed a button
and you can sort of get a sense that
there's a little bit of a
maybe like here's a face the ffa
response goes up here again house goes
up but it's kind of hard to tell
so really the way to analyze these data
is to take
all the face-to-house flips
right
and align them in signal average to get
rid of noise
okay so we can look at the what happens
at you know before and after a switch
from face to house and what happens in
the opposite direction switch everybody
get the idea
it's just a way to clean up the noise
here
and here's what happens
this is time zero the subject presses a
button
saying that their percept has flipped
between a house to a face
the response in the ffa shoots up and
the response in the ppa shoots down
that cool
okay now why
are these peaks and valleys um
after the button press
yeah it's fmri there's a delayed signal
right
okay
this is harder why do they come back
together out there
yeah because it flips back
it flips back
and all we've done is signal average to
one button press but they're different
durations of percepts sometimes it lasts
three seconds sometimes it lasts 10
seconds everything in between by the
time you're 12 seconds out most people
have flipped again that's why it goes
back
okay makes sense
um
i don't know and i'm not sure that that
was generally true i hadn't noticed that
before but we should scrutinize the
images i can't actually remember if this
was averaged over subjects or if this is
one subject i suspect that's a fluke but
we could look at it and see
okay so the point of all of this
is that we can that these regions the
face area and the place area care about
what you are experiencing unconfounded
from what's hitting your retina
right they are reflecting the contents
of your awareness not just what's coming
into your eyes
which is cool
um okay
so that shows that these regions kind of
track awareness
okay
but can we find any evidence
for perception without awareness using
neuroimaging
okay
so to make this point i'm going to
accelerate slightly but i think there's
just barely time
there are lots and lots of studies of
this genre and i'll tell you about one
so i'm going to show you i'm going to
flash up a very rapid series of digits
you have to get ready to write write
stuff down
your task is to
see if there are any letters in the
digit there might be zero there might be
one there might be a few write down any
letters you see it's going to go by
really fast okay everyone ready
okay
here we go
okay write down any letters you may have
seen
okay
all right
let's do another one everyone ready
okay write down any letters you may have
seen
okay
okay
raise your hand if you saw both the a
and the p in the first sequence
a few of you less than half
raise your hand if you saw both the x
and the h and the second almost everyone
all right well i cheated slightly but i
never mind how i cheated but the way you
cheat in demos you guys will be teaching
someday
you have the one you want people to get
wrong first it's total cheat so slightly
cheated but if you do it right
didn't work last year that's why i
cheated anyway if you even if you do it
right in the lab you get a really strong
effect
where when there was only one digit
between the a and the p in the first
sequence
and it's like your brain is still
dealing with the a when the p comes
along you just don't even see the p
you're looking for letters you don't see
it
whereas there were three digits between
the x and the h
in the second sequence and just to show
you some real data
um so this has been done lots of
different ways here's an example of this
experiment and this is the percent of
the time that people get the second
letter when they don't have to report
the first well first one's colored right
so you either have to report the colored
letter and detect the letter after it or
just detect the letter after the colored
thing so if you don't have to report the
first one there's no dip in accuracy oh
sorry this is a function of the distance
between the two items in the sequence
but if you do there's a big dip
that's maximal with uh one intervening
item
yeah
okay
um well here it says two or three but
anyway
um
okay so that's called the attentional
blink and the idea is there isn't a
physical blink of the eyes but your
attention system is tied up processing
the first target and it doesn't get the
second one
okay so there are dozens probably
hundreds of papers on this phenomenon
it's pretty cool
but for present purposes we're going to
use it to say
does that unseen second target get into
the brain
presumably it lands on the retina
because you didn't blink so it probably
got there probably got the v1 how far up
the system did it get
can you think of how we might test this
using functional mri
how would we see how far
that's those stimuli go in an experiment
like this
what would we use what would we measure
the mri response to
how could we design a version of this
that you could do with functional mri
we need some mri response
where if we get that response
we know that it's a response to a given
stimulus
what would we measure
and what stimuli would we use
basis or something yeah
it's always the same yeah phases and
houses
lots of ways to do this but
it's not even my experiment in the used
faces and houses okay so they did a
version of that very same thing there's
a bunch of garbage flashing on
early on there's a face the subjects
have to say which of those three faces
they've studied it is and then after
that a scene comes on or it doesn't come
on
okay they have to just say was there a
scene
first of all which face was it and was
there a scene afterwards
okay so it's a variant to the thing you
just did so here's the behavioral data
if you don't have to report the face
then you are very accurate reporting the
scene if you do have to report the face
then you're very you're very bad at it
if the scene comes right after but if
there's a big interval in between you do
okay with the c same thing we saw before
but now with faces and scenes okay
that's a behavioral data
what do you see in the ppa right the
second target is always a scene
so what you see in the ppa
here's a response in the ppa
to that second scene
if it's a hit that is if you detect it
right you correctly say yes there was a
scene in that trial
here's a response with a correct reject
there was no scene in that trial and you
correctly said there was not okay so
that difference shows you the response
in the ppa to a scene
that you've seen that you detected
consciously
but here's the critical case
i don't know why there's a little pop up
there anyway this is a case where there
was a scene
but you've said there wasn't
okay that's called a miss you missed it
it was there and you didn't see it
and what it shows you
is two cool things well first of all
it tells you that the more aware you are
of the stimulus the stronger response
but the crucial thing it shows you
is this difference right here which is
significant this is a kind of perception
without awareness
you did not detect the scene you said
there was no scene but your ppa detected
the difference
everybody get that
so we have evidence for perception by
the ppa at least
of a scene without awareness
does that make sense
so there are many many studies like this
that kind of
take it every which way this is just one
little example of how you can use
neuroimaging to ask you know how far up
the system does an unseen stimulus get
make sense
okay so we are about out of time um and
i i just gave you a little taste of some
of the work on neural correlates of
awareness
showing you with binocular rivalry a
neural response that's correlated with
awareness unconfounded from the stimulus
uncoupling again perceptual awareness
from what's hitting your retin-a
and in the case of the attentional blink
some evidence for perceptual
representation without awareness
okay